the hype for x-men apocalypse is at an
all-time high and we're not long left
until the film hits the cinema screens
20th Century Fox have teased the world
with one minute worth of mutant madness
I'm Simon and this is your entertainment
news updates 20th Century Fox have
posted a new clip for its upcoming
superhero film Xmen apocalypse the
footage shows a cage fight in which
angel played by X EastEnders star Ben
Hardy attacks a captured Nightcrawler
played by Kodi smit-mcphee while
Jennifer Lawrence as mystique observes
from outside earlier this week Fox
released several promos for the film
including a featurette detailing the
film's villain apocalypse the full
trailer released in April revealed that
the fan-favorite Wolverine would also be
making an appearance in the film a few
days ago a power piece on angel was also
released alongside a new television
promo for the film Xmen apocalypse is
directed by bryan singer who made the
first two movies in the series and
return for 2014's hugely successful Days
of Future past Xmen apocalypse will be
released on May twenty seventh this year
and stars Michael Fassbender James
McAvoy Oscar Isaac nicholas hoult and
rose byrne are you looking forward to
Xmen apocalypse i know i am with peter
bill from EastEnders playing angel I'm
hoping we'll see and bill was mr.
sinister or maybe Phil Mitchell as the
juggernaut let me know how excited you
are for the film in the comments or come
find me on Twitter i'm at the Jagan or
thanks for watching and for your
entertainment news keep it gamespot